hey leute was gedacht und jetzt
willkommen beim ein video heute mal
wieder gestartet hier aus dem aufzug
sich jemand so gut auf jeden fall geht
es heute nach langer zeit mal wieder um
mein auto beziehungsweise mein auto als
es gibt ein auto video ein sprecher
morgen losgefahren sein das hat mir
irgendwie heute nacht wieder geschneit
also das wetter in köln ist echt komisch
dann hat es geregnet also es hat
irgendwie echt keinen spaß gemacht und
ich glaube ein bisschen regnet es auch
immer noch
auf jeden fall das auto ist so dreckig
eigentlich müsste ich es vorher noch
waschen mache ich aber nicht weil das
ding ist wenn ich dann wasche und wieder
nach hause fahren weil die autobahn ist
es bei dem wetter wieder dreckig so
leute ihr fragt euch jetzt sicherlich
was machen wir denn heute ich würde
sagen wir fahren jetzt erst mal los ich
suche mir irgend ein schönes plätzchen
und dann erklären weil es weitere also
bis gleich so leiterin zehn jahren habe
ich auch endlich mal ein parkplatz
gefunden hatten wir da ist das kölner
stadion
es ist auf jeden fall immer noch ein
bisschen am regnen aber ja ich bekomme
wirklich vor allem super instagram oder
auch manchmal bei youtube so kleine
fragen gestellt was wir das auto angeht
ich weiß es kann es auch länger schon
nichts mehr dazu aber ich wollte dieses
video hat irgendwie mal gemacht haben
weil ich finds selber interessant und er
bevor ich jetzt einfach so einen fragen
und antworten video machte zu dem auto
habe ich mir einfach mal gedacht so ich
hab das jetzt ein halbes jahr und in
diesem halben jahr sind wir natürlich
viele sachen aufgefallen die echt mega
cool sind
es gibt natürlich auch ein paar
nachteile das gehört ja immer dazu und
ja darum sollten dem heutigen video
gehen also einfach mal vor und nachteile
meine eigene meinung bzw rezension nach
einem halben jahr ja ziemlich dreckig
ich wollte also ich habe mir gestern
einfach mal ein paar punkte
aufgeschrieben einfach halt vor und
nachteile da ist so fett weil ich zeige
euch das war kurz schaut euch das mal
richtig leid
ja leute also nochmal schlauerweise
vorher so sieht das auto aus sodass ich
habe mich gestern auf jeden fall einmal
hingesetzt ich hoffe das bleibt jetzt
stehen und hab mir punkte auf
beschrieben die mich halt am auto so ein
bisschen stören erstmal muss man aber
auf jeden fall gesagt haben so die
vorteile sind natürlich krasser
überwiegen also den mega zufrieden mit
dem auto ist echt richtig geil und ich
bin sehr froh dass ich jetzt wird das
auto entschieden habe und nicht für eine
ahnung
die oder was auch sonst schaut euch
einfach mal dieses wetter an eben lag
hier noch alles voll mit schnee jetzt
ist alles wieder weg ok deswegen würde
ich jetzt einfach mal sagen ich fange
von hier drin an weil es halt draußen
regnet wie schon eben kurz erwähnt ich
bin echt mega zufrieden mit dem auto ist
mein absolutes traumauto also wirklich
auch immer noch und ich würde diese
entscheidung auch jederzeit wieder
treffen ich hab's ja auch schon öfter
mal gesagt was ich so extrem feier an
diesem auto aber vielleicht das nochmal
für die leute die sich nur das video
anschauen weil sie sich vielleicht
selber ein ähnliches auto holen wollen
oder sonst was ich bin jetzt nicht der
heftigste autokenner das weiß ich selber
aber ist ja klar kann ja auch nicht
jeder sein
ich denke das ist vielleicht auch ganz
gut natürlich kann ich mich mit dem auto
mittlerweile eigentlich ziemlich gut aus
und deswegen denke ich will das auch ein
ganz informatives video hoffe ich mal
also der erste punkt den ich mir
ausgesucht habe wenn man das hier schon
sieht ich sitze hier wirklich immer ich
bin super froh dass ich hier diese
ledersitze gewählt habe es gibt auch so
sportsitze die wollte ich halt erst
haben nur ich glaube da ich auch
ziemlich oft so lange strecke fahre
werde es schon echt nervig gewesen aber
diese sitze ohne witzig war noch in
keinem auto ich kenne kein anderes auto
in dem ich bis jetzt drin gesessen haben
wo ich gesagt habe deine sitze sind
bequemer als meine das ist echt ne geile
sitze die auch so ein paar features
finde ich haben die echt entspannt sind
man kann die sitze an der seite ganz
einfach elektronisch verstellen hoch
unterschieben das auto hat auf der einen
seite natürlich eine sitzheizung die man
auf drei stufen verstellen kann aber
auch eine sitzung was für den sommer
echt extrem geil ist ich meine gut jetzt
es ist kalt da braucht man sowas nicht
aber im sommer mega ein spannendes
feature also danke dafür
also die sitze feiere ich mega und wenn
man sich hier umschaut also ich finde
den innenraum so echt mega gute sein das
ist jetzt nicht zu viel aber es ist auch
nicht zu wenig also es gibt echt viele
features man kann das licht verstellen
man hat auf dem lenkrad eigentlich alles
was man so braucht das sollte aber
eigentlich der nächste punkt seien nur
ich fühle mich hier wirklich immer wenn
ich drin sitzen mega wohl und freue mich
wirklich immer aufs neue wieder mit dem
auto fahren zu töten so ich würde sagen
jetzt gehen wir aber nochmal raus und
machen von draußen weiter wir haben hier
irgendwie so eine hundewiese und hier
sind echt ziemlich viele große wunde die
mich hoffentlich gleich nicht anfallen
so kommen wir als nächstes zum lenkrad
dann habe ich ja gerade schon
angesprochen ich finde das lenkrad auch
vom design erstmal richtig cool vor
allem das pferd da drauf und man hat
aber wirklich so ich sag mal so nicht zu
viele knöpfe aber auch nicht zu wenig
das passt genau man kann sprachsteuerung
aktivieren man kann die lautstärke von
der musik regeln was auch extrem cool
ist der tempomat ist genau am lenkrad
mit dran so jetzt hat sich auch schon
wieder drin
wir waren beim lenkrad tempomat ist
einfach auf dem lenker drauf ist nicht
dahinter bei ihren eltern zum beispiel
die haben vw ist der tempomat dahinter
da finde ich das hier wäre es nicht
besser gelöst kann man einfach entspannt
anklicken vorstellen wie man möchte also
das lenkrad das wirklich top einfach zu
verstehen ich habe hier auf jeden fall
einige knöpfe zum herumspielen also das
freilich auch sehr was man hier dann
auch wirklich sagen muss viele haben ja
immer so oder denken so sportwagen der
kofferraum ist extrem klein ist ja auch
verständlich ich meine es gibt viele
gute beispiele wo der kofferraum sehr
klein ist hier muss man allerdings sagen
der kofferraum ist wirklich extrem groß
das hätte ich selber nicht gedacht dass
da so viel rein passt also ich würde
schätzen da passen auf jeden fall ja so
gut sechs handgepäck verein man könnte
sonst auch noch einfach die
notfallsitzung klappen dann hat man noch
mehr platz also man könnte auch sagen
wieso ein brett hierdurch schieben wir
auch kein problem ich glaube ich war
eben noch beim premium paket stehen
geblieben da habe ich noch nicht so viel
zugesagt also hier ist das premium paket
zwei darin verbaut kostet ungefähr 2000
euro mehr
man hat dann allerdings noch einige
extra features also das lohnt sich
wirklich sehr wenn ich da jetzt zum
beispiel an den amg denke oder so da
kann man ja wirklich noch echt eine
menge geld ausgeben um alle features
drin zu haben hier gibt es 2000 euro
mehr aus und hast eigentlich alles was
man so wirklich braucht das ist schon
echt gut und ich finde wenn man sich
dann das auto holt sollte man auch
darauf achten dass das premium paket mit
dabei ist so jetzt fällt mir auf ich
könnte eigentlich auch wieder rausgehen
hat aufgehört was mir auch wirklich sehr
gut gefällt ist die soundanlage hier
muss ich jetzt wenig sagen ich weiß
nicht was genau das für boxen sind sie
sind auf jeden fall mega krass ich kann
manchmal kurzen soundcheck machen ich
weiß nicht ob man das auf der kamera
jetzt auch so gehört aber das sind
wirklich richtig gute boxen der basis
geil und das klingt halt so 0 wie man
das in vielen autos hat wenn man es
weiter auftritt so plastik plastik haft
ist ein super wort immer wenn ich
rausgehe fängt sie an zu regnen es
klingt halt wirklich selbst auf der
höchsten stufe noch fett und das war ich
auch was eigentlich das geist ist wo ich
mich eigentlich erschrocken habe ich
dachte er ist da irgendwas falsch also
das hätte ich wirklich ganz anders
eingestellt man denkt ja immer so musste
der verbraucht unmengen an sprit das ist
jetzt auch nicht der gt sondern
der eco boost verbraucht logischerweise
ein bisschen weniger durch hätte ich
jetzt auch so mit 11 12 litern gerechnet
eigentlich aber ich fahre also ich würde
mal sagen durchschnitt auf der autobahn
160 und ich war wirklich noch nie über
neuneinhalb meter auf 100 kilometer was
schon eigentlich echt cool ist also da
verbraucht auch der von meinen eltern
zum beispiel mehr und was auch einfach
geiles man kann das auto abschließen
geht hin muss es nicht mehr aufmachen
und das geht von alleine wieder auf weil
der schlüssel in der nähe ist so das
waren die ganzen vorteile
jetzt kommen noch einige nachteile die
man finde ich hätte besser machen können
allerdings ist das jetzt auch paige und
vergangen ich hoffe die kamera durch
lässt nicht so wie es regnet was ich
wirklich blöd finde vor allem wenn man
dann in der stadt fährt erst mal nachts
ich weiß nicht die scheiben sind mir so
ein bisschen komisch getönt ich mal auch
wenn sie gar nicht wirklich getönt sind
aber wenn ich dann zum beispiel mit dem
auto von wenn eltern fahren nachts
wirklich eine viel bessere sich das
liegt wahrscheinlich auch daran weil das
auto ziemlich tief liegt und weil an der
seite hier dieser bogen ziemlich große
sowie machen jetzt von innen weiter
regte wieder viel zu viel draußen
ich gehe mal raus dann fängt plötzlich
wieder an also man muss wirklich voll
wenn sich in köln wenn man viele
fahrradfahrer hat die auch auf denken
hey wir sind hier ganz alleine auf der
straße man muss um sich schauen und auch
gut malen den schulterblick machen weil
hier einfach die rundumsicht finde ich
nicht so gut ist aber was will man auch
erwarten wenn dein auto als relativ weit
unten liegt die scheiben jetzt nicht
besonders groß sind dann sollte man sich
nicht so ein auto holen ist klar was ich
dann aber wirklich sehr schade finde ich
glaube das hätte man auch noch einbauen
können nur wenn man sich mal die
schnauze angriff vom auto die ist so
lang hinten ist ein pieper drin vorne
nicht aber dass wir besser wer vorne
drin und hinten nicht vor allem wenn man
halt hier in köln durch parkhäuser fährt
oder so die sind oft sehr eng vor allem
die in der innenstadt da wäre es schon
manchmal coolen pieper halt vorne auf
den sommer gibt wahrscheinlich auch noch
ein fachausdruck für kenne ich nicht
schönen guten tag man lernt dass damit
derzeit abzuschätzen
aber ja ist halt trotzdem manchmal ein
bisschen nervig und dann muss ich da
ziemlich oft konzentrieren dass man halt
wirklich gucken die kurve kommen wir zur
sprachsteuerung da habe ich mich auch
sehr gefreut dass das hier drin ist ich
muss nur sagen diese frauenstimme die
davert die fakten ich wirklich so also
die sprachsteuerung ist wirklich das was
mich an diesem auto so dermaßen ankotzt
und auch ziemlich oft schon richtig
aggressiv gemacht hat also erstens
versteht ihr mich gar nicht immer und
zweitens laverty so viel unnötiges zeug
das man wirklich abgelenkt ist von der
fahrbahn
ich zeige euch einfach mal kurz die
sprachsteuerung dazu drückt man einfach
hier auf diesen knopf
1 kommentar bitte ich sage es einfach
mal irgendwas blablabla anrufen bloß
weil ich habe sie nicht verstanden
sie können den 3 fm im sb oder
navigations sagen die lager das holzoval
minuten bunten ist nennen sie den namen
eines kontaktes und sagen sie anrufen
beispielsweise max mustermann anrufen
oder sagen sie wäre gefolgt von der
telefonnummer
zum beispiel wählen 01 98 was eine
also was zum beispiel kommt dann er war
die erzählt dann gern mal eine halbe
stunde
das gleiche ist auch bei der navigation
so also die gebe ich schon gar nicht
mehr über dieses sprachsteuerung ein das
funktioniert ähnlich also das ist finde
ich ein bisschen geld gemacht als lenker
auf jeden fall ab aber ja was willst du
machen das gleiche gilt dann auch für
navigationssysteme natürlich ist es
immer cool wenn so was man drin ist nur
weil es mich dann schon zweimal zum
falschen ziel gebracht hat obwohl ich
die richtige adresse eingegeben habe
denke ich mir
willst du mich verarschen und was ich
auch noch dazu sagen muss ich finde es
manchmal ein bisschen unübersichtlich
man weiß nicht glauben muss ich jetzt
hier ablegen oder muss ich da abbiegen
also das haben andere autohersteller
finde ich ein bisschen besser gelöst
aber ist natürlich jetzt auch kein
weltuntergang
dann kommt noch hinzu was ich eigentlich
gar nicht wirklich verstehen wir haben
ihn logischerweise überall so
abdichtungen auch hinten am kofferraum
nur vor allem hier am rand wie das auto
irgendwie extrem schnell dreckig ich
weiß nicht woran es liegt man muss halt
wenn man dann in die waschstraße fährt
auch mal schön hier diesen diesen rand
hier putzen weil sich da wie auch immer
ziemlich viel dreck angesammelt das
gleiche gilt auch für den kofferraum
dass es auch oftmals so dass ich da halt
so netter verfangen ist ein kleiner
nachteil muss man jetzt eigentlich gar
nicht groß über meckern ist halt einfach
so dann was ich witzig finde der
tankdeckel selbst du nicht das auto
abschließe kann man den tankdeckel
öffnen also es könnte nachts irgendein
vorgekommen und mir da sonst was rein
kippen und ich würde es gar nicht merken
nur ich habe da eine methode gefunden
den abzudecken auch wenn das auto hält
dann abgeschlossen ist und irgendwo
steht also mein kann man nicht einfach
öffnen das war aber mal so und was mir
dann auch mal aufgefallen ist ich dachte
irgendwie die motorhaube wäre kaputt
aber das ist halt irgendwie ganz normal
bei mustern so ab 180 fängt ja ich
ziemlich an zu flattern
da kann man auch teile einbauen dass das
nicht mehr so ist aber das halte ich
eigentlich für eher unnötig irgendwann
gewöhnt man sich dran dann achtet man
gar nicht mehr drauf das werden halt so
nachteile ab so leute und so sieht der
schlüssel auf soweit ich bin wieder zu
hause ist übels angefangen zu regnen
wenn euch das video gefallen hat was
daumen nach oben da wäre es informativ
endet schreibt was in die kommentare wir
sehen uns morgen wieder haut rein